mais on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés Patricia Lemonia bonjour
Patricia et Bruno Daru de la rédaction
de France 24 bonjour Bruno Raphaël la
dernière fois qu'il s'était vu Vladimir
Poutine avait envahi l'Ukraine dans la
foulée que va faire le leader rue cette
fois alors qu'il retrouve chez Jean Ping
le président chinois qui l'assure du
soutien de la Chine écouté
face à un monde une époque et une
histoire en constante évolution la Chine
est prête à faire des efforts avec la
Russie pour assumer le rôle des grandes
puissances et joue un rôle de guide
pour apporter stabilité énergie positive
dans un monde secoué par les troubles
sociaux
d'État chinoises également à suivre
Vladimir Poutine que la Chine était
prête je cite à travailler avec la
Russie un soutien ferme et mutuel sur
les questions liées aux intérêts
fondamentaux de chacun et approfondir la
coopération Patricia lemonaire c'est
cela l'objectif de cette rencontre
resserrer les liens face aux menaces
extérieures
Ukraine d'un côté Taïwan de l'autre
alors moi si vous me permettez je trouve
pas si j'ai une pince si euh allant
vis-à-vis
de Vladimir Poutine d'abord
on s'inquiète un peu mais il parle quand
même dans un monde en chaos
ce monde en chaos d'où vient le chaos
qui a créé le chaos c'est que la Chine
est très attachée à l'intégrité
territoriale le chinois est passé juste
avant au Kazakhstan et a dit au
président kazak que il n'était hors de
question que ça ne sont intégrité
territoriale soit menacée parce qu'à
Moscou même moment des gens disaient que
ce petit Kazakhstan qui prenait un peu
qui critiquait un peu Moscou pour son
attitude visée de l'Ukraine pourrait
peut-être revenir un peu dans le giron
russe donc c'est pas aussi simple je
crois que le calcul chinois c'est
d'afficher effectivement cette bonne
entente mais avec derrière deux idées un
ne pas aller trop loin pour quand même
pas fâcher l'Amérique avec lequel on
fait du business
et ça c'est important et deuxièmement
l'autre idée c'est quand même l'huile
patron regardez comment il se tient
Royal détendu souriant regardez comment
et Poutine face à lui plus rabougri on
l'a jamais vu à le revoir après avec le
l'Iranien assis très en forme mais parce
que Racine rien par rapport on a
l'impression physiquement le rapport de
force et on a l'impression qu'en fait
pour le chinois bien ma foi la Russie va
sale la Russie dépendante économiquement
c'est pas trop mal c'est plutôt un bon
calcul alors Vladimir Poutine lui en
rajoute sur le thème de l'adversaire
occidental écouter le
les tentatives de créer un monde
unipolaire ont récemment pris une forme
absolument LED et son totalement
inacceptables
nous apprécions grandement la position
équilibrée de nos amis chinois face à la
crise ukrainienne
la Russie n'est pas isolée elle a des
alliés c'est cela que cherchent à
montrer vladima Poutine momentanément
affaibli en Ukraine Bruno oui alors
c'est clairement le message que veut
faire passer ou Vladimir Poutine parce
que effectivement vous l'avez dit
actuellement à l'armée russe traverse
une passe un peu quand même difficile en
Ukraine à tout l'Occident contre contre
elle donc oui Vladimir Poutine veut dire
regarder nous avons quand même beaucoup
d'alliés parmi les plus puissants mais
je suis assez d'accord avec Patricia
dans un rapport quand même qui est très
très ambigu parce que la superpuissance
dans l'affaire c'est la Chine et non pas
à la Russie et c'est Vladimir Poutine
qui a besoin de montrer qu'il a des
soutiens pour montrer qu'il n'est pas
isolé et puis d'ailleurs dans ce sommet
de l'Organisation de coopération de
Shanghai il y a justement les les ex
républiques soviétiques dont le
Kazakhstan qui se méfie un peu des
velléités expansionnistes effectivement
de la Russie et qui donc sont plutôt
assez contentes de montrer une certaine
proximité avec la Chine qui elle joue de
sa puissance pour faire bien comprendre
à ses ex République soviétiques elle
respecte effectivement l'INT
territoriale et que donc en fait elles
n'ont rien à craindre tant qu'elles sont
sous le parapluie chinois donc pour
l'instant quand même pour Vladimir
Poutine c'est pas mal parce qu'il peut
montrer qu'il est pas isolé mais enfin
le grand gagnant de dans cette affaire
c'est quand même le président chinois
chez jimping bon alors il a en plus le
soutien de la dire Poutine qui a
réaffirmé le soutien à une Chine unie
donc c'est-à-dire que la Russie s'aligne
totalement sur Pékin concernant Taïwan
pour chez gimping c'est tout bénéfice
comme on dit
cette organisation de coopération de
Shanghai avait été lancée en 2001 bon à
l'époque la Chine devenait tout juste
d'intégrer ce qui était à l'époque le
gars le commerce l'OMC langue enfin ce
qui est devenu par la suite l'OMC
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce il y
a participé à ce cette expansion
phénoménale de la Chine aujourd'hui
alors qu'elle a atteint d'une certaine
matière d'une certaine manière la
maturité dans le contexte actuel elle
peut se substituer au commerce et
relations avec les occidentaux pour des
pays comme la Chine comme l'Inde
Patricia
je pense pas je pense que la Chine a
toujours besoin comme je vous l'ai dit
beaucoup des États-Unis l'export et les
relations c'est trois fois plus que par
exemple viser de la Chine la Chine a
besoin et on est à marché formidable
marché européen rien à voir avec le
marché des républics soviétique etc
américain donc rien à voir la Chine a
besoin et elle l'a bien compris en
revanche cette organisation cette
coopération de Shanghai c'est c'est un
boulevard extraordinaire pour la Chine
pour asseoir la route de la soie et la
Route de la Soie effectivement elle a
investi plus de 100 milliards dans cette
route de la soie et Moscou en devenant
en quelque sorte vassal de la Chine va
faciliter cette pénétration chinoise qui
arrive de ce fait jusque jusqu'en Europe
en Allemagne en
les trains vont arriver les containers
va arriver chez nous et donc c'est dans
cette histoire là dans ce désordre là la
Chine espère bien
tirer des avantages et quand la Chine on
le voit aujourd'hui dit non non mais moi
je me retire je retire mes grandes
entreprises privées d'ailleurs de Russie
je retire
d'autres se dire mais ils vont pas loin
ils vont juste à côté ils attendent et
puis la Chine
est très amie avec l'Iran donc il suffit
de vendre à l'Iran pour revendre à la
Russie donc si vous voulez tout un autre
la Chine c'est très bien qu'elle peut
remettre en marche tout un autre système
pour détourner les sanctions pour pas
s'exposer aux sanctions américaines et
pour trouver une autre route comme elle
a fait avec l'Iran dans un premier temps
et comme elle a fait avec la Corée donc
la Chine joue un jeu très abîme mais son
objectif premier c'est asseoir sa
puissance économique et batte l'Amérique
sur un plan économique et l'Amérique le
sait
ça c'est pour l'aspect économique mais
il y a aussi des dossiers chauds du
moment la crise entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan la Syrie qui continue
quand même on évoque d'ailleurs une
visite peut-être prochaine de regga
hyper douanes sur place on pourrait
assister à des avancées à l'occasion de
ce sommet Bruno on verra bien dommage
pas persuadé que on assiste à des
avancées très concrètes sur ces dossiers
concernant les récents affrontement
entre l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan le
président Alif a été invité donc oui
sans lui on lui donne on lui donne un
peu un gage mais je pense pas
franchement que ça ira que ça ira
tellement plus loin personnellement
pourrait bouger c'est le dossier syrien
avec un rapprochement avec Bachar
el-Assad aurait évoqué un moment à temps
même peut-être une présence de Bachir
al-Assad dans ce sommet une rencontre
possible entre les deux hommes la godie
sur le dossier syrien un peu avec tous
les acteurs c'est pas bon puisque quand
même très fermement les djihadistes bon
là là aujourd'hui de toute façon le
rapprochement avec le gouvernement de
Damas il est il est déjà entamé il est
déjà il est déjà acté donc non
l'avantage parce que la Turquie ne fait
pas partie de cette organisation de
coopération l'avantage d'être un des
deux invités un peu exceptionnelles avec
le Président alief c'est de montrer à
quel point il est devenu un acteur
important sur la scène régionale erdon
c'est toujours pareil il joue sur les
deux tableaux il joue sur le tableau
occidental appartenant à l'OTAN et en
faisant sa médiation notamment sur le
dossier des céréales en Ukraine et en
même temps de ne votant pas les
sanctions contre la Russie il joue sur
tous les tableaux donc là il vient un
peu se faire un peu introniser dans
cette partie là du monde en fait oui ce
qui est étonnant dans ce dans ce sommet
c'est qu'on a quatre personnages qui se
rêvent au centre d'Empire
Erdogan en pierre turc le chinois
l'empire chinois le Russe l'empire des
arts et les Iraniens le pays du centre
maudit aussi les autres voilà et puis
l'Indien mais l'Indien lui a déjà son
empire tout ça il a déjà son espace mais
tous les autres c'était un lieu où les
dirigeants se rêvent enfin rêve d'Empire
autoritaires
qui sont temporaires vous voyez qui sont
de circonstances plus que d'un projet
alors c'est un front du refus la seule
chose qu'il les unit finalement c'est le
front de refus par rapport à l'Occident
et c'est là où c'est grave et c'est là
où vous qu'on se méfie parce que ils
veulent entraîner derrière eux tout le
reste de la planète
tous là ils représentent pas loin de la
moitié de
être un anti G7 ça suffit à bâtir une
alternative viable non ça suffit pas
complètement à bâtir une alternative
viable parce que quand même la grande
faiblesse si on met la Chine à part la
grande faiblesse de ces pays c'est au
niveau économique quand même hein même
la Russie n'est que je crois la 11e ou
le 12e puissance économique mondiale
donc comparé quand même aux économies
évidemment américaines et européenne
effectivement comme je n'ai pas touché à
tout à l'heure ces pays-là ils pèsent
pas enfin il pèse évidemment mais enfin
il ne passe pas grand chose pour faire
basculer si vous voulez l'ordre
géopolitique
alors et la Chine le sait très bien la
Russie qu'on évoquait en tout cas accusé
par Washington a notamment de financer
les campagnes de certains partis
politiques et personnalités on pense
évidemment à l'extrême droite ici en
Europe nombre de leaders ont affiché
leur indulgence voire parfois même leur
admiration envers Vladimir Poutine or
c'est précisément en ce moment que
l'extrême droite effectue une percée sur
le continent en Suède dimanche dernier
ou avec un peu plus de 20% des suffrages
et le s'impose comme incontournable de
la future coalition vous le voyez 176
sièges de députés pour le bloc constitué
des conservateurs mais également des
démocrates de Suède qui sont comme leur
nom ne l'indique pas la frange d'extrême
droite du pays à suivre dans 10 jours
les élections en Italie avec en position
de force si on en croit les sondages le
parti Fratelli d'Italia de Georgia
Meloni c'est une tendance lourde
Patricia comment vous l'expliquez oui je
crois que c'est une tendance lourde
comme vous le dites je crois aussi que
c'est un une
erreur d'analyse
des parties du centre des parties
libéraux qui qui n'ont pas voulu comme
disent les Anglais adresses qui n'ont
pas voulu s'attaquer à ce qui minent les
démocraties occidentales aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement
l'émigrations et ne voulant pas
s'y attaquer à ce problème et au nom de
la solidarité au nom d'un humanisme très
généreux et bien elles n'ont pas réglé
ce problème dans le discours parce que
dans les faits et ceux qui nous
entendent notamment sur le continent
africain savent bien que l'Europe est
restée quasi hermétique au moment de
population
pour ce qui est l'immigration légale
hermétique enfin
en Suède pas hermétique puisque la Suède
a ouvert massivement ses frontières
aussi rien et beaucoup de d'autres
nationalités donc si vous voulez pas
cyrmer et l'Italie avant l'arrivée de
partir d'extrême droite aussi était très
ouverte c'est un pays où il y a eu
énormément
d'arriver et donc on ne voulant pas au
nom d'un humanisme comprendre qu'une
partie une catégorie de la population
les plus les plus pauvres la classe
moyenne la plus fragilisée et bien c'est
parti on fait défaut ça c'est un premier
point et autre problème c'est que c'est
parti et moi je l'ai beaucoup vu dans
dans les pays où il y a eu des
révolutions et des parties comme comme
en Égypte comme dans les pays du Maghreb
quand les les démocrates en quelque
sorte il ne salit jamais je ne sais pas
pourquoi ce qu'ils ont les démocrates
ils sont toujours en train de se tirer
en télépathe il ne s'agit jamais alors
comme ils sont désunis chacun a vendant
sa petite chapelle et bien par rapport à
ceux qui sont unis et bien il baisse la
crise à donner Emmanuel Macron à qui on
reproche précisément d'avoir fait monter
l'extrême droite faute d'alternative oui
on va je sais pas si ils sont tellement
unis ou si c'était un défaut de
président ça c'est autre chose
Bruno darrou sur la montée de l'extra on
évoquera peut-être aussi la conséquence
sur le front vis-à-vis de la Russie mais
peut-être d'abord une analyse sur cette
montée vous vous voyez comme ça un
phénomène général il faut pas neuf non
c'est préoccupant si on regarde les
résultats en Suède ça reste quand même
extrêmement serrées la Suède c'est très
symbolique parce que évidemment c'était
le the country de l'associal démocratie
et donc produire dans les années 60-70
c'était le modèle qui inspiré et les
sociaux-démocrates en Europe du Sud
notamment donc il y a un côté un peu
symbolique après c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
des je suis d'accord avec Patricia des
problèmes sur l'immigration que certains
démocrates voilà ne veulent pas voir en
face parce que par exemple en Suède ils
sont 10 millions mais aujourd'hui je
crois qu'on en est à 2 millions 20 %
quand même de suédois qui ne sont pas
suédois d'origine donc une immigration
donc voilà l'immigration donc ça pose
quand même un problème pour une partie
ça se passe très bien mais pour certains
il y a quand même des problèmes
d'insécurité etc et les les l'accueil de
la Suède récemment a fait qu'il y a eu
quand même sur ces 20% 10% qui sont
arrivés très récemment donc ça fait
quand même beaucoup donc ces
préoccupants ce qui va se passer en
Italie se préoccupant mais ce sont quand
même effectivement deux pays qui ont eu
des à gérer de plein fouet des poussées
des poussées migratoires après on peut
quand même un peu se consoler entre
guillemets en constatant qu'en Allemagne
la FD est un peu en recul et qu'en
France pour le moment même si euh
subsiste mais il y a aussi le fait qu'il
y ait aussi assez préoccupant qui fait
que les cordons sanitaires tombent c'est
parti là comment Suède et comme en
France ce banalisent prennent des
couleurs douces etc et donc du coup bah
ça fait que les parties de centre droit
et de droite se disent bon allez on peut
gouverner avec eux c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer en Suède la
conséquence de ce mouvement de cette
progression des parties d'extrêmement on
évoquait peut-être la Russie qui agite
les ficelles derrière les rideaux est-ce
que cela va contribuer à fissurer ce
front européen qui pour leur tient face
à la Russie justement dans la crise
ukrainienne alors c'est toute la
question que va faire par exemple
italienne
elle est très anti-européenne
elle est atlantise mais en même temps
contre Bruxelles j'ai envie de dire elle
est plutôt contre Bruxelles elle est
elle a des positions très dures
vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne donc si vous
voulez les fractures à l'intérieur de
l'Europe vont vont s'élargir j'ai envie
de dire mais je crois que toujours c'est
toujours pareil face à l'adversité
on a compris quand même qu'il fallait
peut-être être quand même deux pays
comme il faut surveiller qui sont déjà
l'Union européenne c'est la Pologne et
surtout la Hongrie et vous avez vu
aujourd'hui que le Parlement européen
quand même à voter une résolution alors
qu'il n'est pas contraignante ni
opérationnelle mais enfin estimant que
la Hongrie ne remplissait plus les
critères d'une démocratie
et du coup voilà la Hongrie est menacée
de ne pas toucher l'argent de Bruxelles
ça va rien l'a dit mais il y a eu en
plus ce vote aujourd'hui Parlement
européen et on voit réagit évidemment
avec beaucoup de vigueur mais le
Parlement quand même énumère toutes les
tous les recules de de l'État de droit
en gris et dit même que aujourd'hui la
Hongrie ne pourrait plus intégrer
l'Union européenne tellement elle ne
respecte pas ses critères donc ça c'est
quand même préoccupant surtout de la
part d'un dirigeant comme Victor Hormann
qui a quand même des intérêts politiques
économiques qui restent quand même assez
puissant avec la Russie merci beaucoup
Bruno Darou merci Patricia Lemonnier RCT
on va plus loin rester avec nous
prochain journal dans moins de 5 minutes
sur France 24